[Music]
have you guys
heard about madonna and her
biopic and how she is the one directing
it and co-writing it
seems like a vanity product i'm
intrigued sounds like a catastrophe
yeah yeah is playing her is she playing
her uh i don't think so okay it doesn't
say starring madonna didn't she direct a
movie already
oh did she oh she's got she's got like i
know that she had a ball
a resume but yeah i think it was i don't
think she directed that i think her
husband was the director or something
right i know that she has acted in quite
a few projects
like a league of their own uh
desperately seeking susan dick tracy's
1990 oh yeah dick tracy 1996 evita
which is i remember that someone should
bring that franchise back don't cry for
me argentina yes that's all i remember
from that movie
see it that's it i just remember the
entire movie they were singing because
it's a musical
but anyway so and then uh swept away and
art
that was it that was the terrible one
swept away what was it yeah i think
swept it was the awful one that guy
was the guy ritchie movie then yeah i
think that was it and then arthur and
the invisibles
she was an arthur in the invisibles oh
you're right it's a uh she did
co-write and direct the 2011
drama w-e right and it did not do well i
heard
or something it was not received well or
something let's
google it we did not like it it doesn't
see the film
it was directed by madonna and where's
twelve percent run tomatoes six point
three out of ten from img
that was the story of that movie that
was like the movies marketing campaign
madonna directed it and it's rough
so was it marketing then it's really bad
exactly but it's marketing
61 of google users liked the movie
though
well that happens a lot um and it's sad
yeah i don't
have a moment of silence for all those
people oh oscar isaac isn't it
oh i like that guy yeah uh so i don't
know i feel like it's gonna be a
catastrophe because it's your own story
and i feel like when you tell your own
story you kind of
see things through rose-colored glasses
yeah you know if you're writing and
directing it and you're the subject of
the thing
you're gonna glaze over some parts that
maybe don't yeah which is the most
compelling parts of most biopics right i
would say the most compelling parts is
kind of dabbling into the
the demons of a certain character right
yeah yeah i don't want to hear
how they're so great she can be
objective about it i mean it could just
be that she's just rewriting her own
past
making her it could be making her like
look better you guys are so cynical
i mean like it could be that's what i'm
saying yeah i don't know
i think it's a i think it's kind of cool
personally that she gets to tell her
own life story like hello it's
her life it's just the same thing as how
people write their autobiographies it's
like
they're telling it from their own lens i
think she should have her ex-husband do
it
[Laughter]
dude i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
where's my dream they just burst into
the room
it's like i'm a [ __ ] it opens like
uncut
gems and it goes like through her
[ __ ]
yeah i love it it opens to his [ __ ]
through his ass
yeah it's like these close-up like
microscopic images of whatever the [ __ ]
and then you realize it's like the
universe and then it comes out through
his rectal exam
yeah [ __ ] great yeah i love it watch
undercut gems
in a certain way too that's kind of
similar to the opening too yeah we'll
talk about that
oh you told me the end oh yeah it's a
great movie it's a fantastic movie i
love that movie with a [ __ ] horrible
entertainment is it what is it called
yeah yeah i will still say it's a good
movie in the
context that it's a as a movie it's good
it's not an enjoyable movie no it is not
unless you like uncomfortable situations
if you go to movies you have a good
time yeah no this is not that much yeah
if you have a wife with a predetermined
amount of anxiety
this movie is terrifying for her she's
like this is not fun why are we watching
this [ __ ]
anxiety attack personified yeah i went
home afterwards and i was like marion
do not watch this movie you are not
having a good time
you will not have a good time at all for
that reason because i was talking to
them
and then i was like guys i'm never gonna
see this movie ever because i avoid
those kind of movies i avoid like
heartbreakingly sad movies and like high
anxiety inducing movies i'm not trying
to do that
10 out of 10 would recommend nikki might
as well been on the [ __ ] tower of
terror ride
she's just sitting there going wow
the genius of that movie is like one of
my favorite things
maximum conflict at all times yeah they
dig up conflict in places you didn't
even expect
what's so good is that nothing crazy
actually really happens at least until
the end right and so it's like
how do they mine it in so much with so
much conflict
now picture that in the diana madonna's
biography i would watch that okay
yeah if you told me it was it was uncut
gems with madonna
yeah whatever sign me up let's do it
yeah so here's a photo of young madonna
just so you guys can remember what is
she she was so [ __ ] hot
i agree she she drips sexuality bro yeah
yeah what about now what about now i
actually think that she's still hot okay
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll fight
anybody pretty well yeah so this is kind
of sort of
current with her in a camera mm-hmm
definitely looks like a
direct like a director channeling little
tim burton there
yeah madonna's one of those people who
loves herself but then you're like
you're [ __ ] madonna like i think
that's allowed
kind of like mariah carey situation
beyonce situation yeah exactly
he's like you get a pass yeah exactly
and they are all labeled as divas
have you seen the i love hydrangeas
video
so somebody gave madonna flowers a very
nice gesture
and then they walk away and she's like
let's take these i loathe hydrangeas
no way she's not even a brit either so
like she like has this like fake british
accent because she lived there just to
talk [ __ ]
wow that lindsay lohan had a fake accent
too like she lived in london for a while
or like somewhere in england and she had
a british accent for a while
weird accent i don't blame them though
because when you're in that environment
like you're just like
oh [ __ ] i didn't realize i started
talking like you i would want to
yeah i remember when i watched a bunch
of sherlock back to back and in my head
i remember i was thinking
like with the british accent the whole
time i don't think i said it out loud
so i actually tried all my thoughts in
an
just try watching the bond movies
without having a [ __ ] british accent
in your head
for a couple days after do they binge
misfits
and that entire show like the way they
talk and [ __ ] it was
in my brain for like weeks and then i
would try to say it out loud i'm like my
tongue can't do it like my mouth just
can't do it it's just
it sounds like a horrible mess were you
guys the right age to be madonna fans
um oh yeah i was too young i don't know
not me
it wasn't a big thing for me i do
remember
seeing her i remember having this
thought when i was really little
which was um wow michael jackson is like
the biggest in the world
and then the female equivalent to that
is madonna like she's like
huge so i remember thinking like man i
don't know why i thought this
but i'm like man if any of them if
either of them
die the entire world is going to stop
like whoa
and then what happened and it's still
still and it happened with michael
for some people it did yeah
we just got stuck in that part of their
lives i guess yeah geez steve joe's not
even here
not even just joe honestly you guys know
what i'm who i'm talking about like when
it comes to people who love michael
jackson who just like
yeah they love it's crazy man yeah yeah
did you know that he wanted to star
and hook yeah he wanted to be peter pan
yeah
i you know a part of me is like
he was in the wiz he was a scarecrow
exactly
i still gotta watch i haven't seen it
either how was he in as a square
scared not as bad as you would think
because you immediately go he's a he's a
pop star you can't really after whatever
he
as a scarecrow was he like really good
at the scarecrow movements
character movements are this that's the
one
if you've ever watched a 35 minute
michael jackson music video you've seen
him act in the wiz
i don't think i've ever seen his
thriller right thriller is like a long
ass it's not 35 minutes
yeah oh dude the full the full thriller
is
is longer than that because there's like
a building there's a build-up oh yeah
yeah
not nothing where the werewolf but the
i've seen it i'm like i did not sit
through three have you watched that have
you watched bad with wesley snyder
that's
long long yeah there's a whole scene of
him at wesley snipers like you're a
sellout you're not from
from our you know you're going to
college and then and then michael
jackson's like well i can be smart
and also cool and he's like what i like
like
i like the voice of mickey mouse
the best [ __ ] the [ __ ] is it's all from
michael's mind so at the end
michael's like i'm gonna snap dance in
front of you and then wesley snape's
you're gonna be like i [ __ ] respect
you
yeah respect you're my brother you're my
brother
oh [ __ ] all right so back to madonna and
her project so
madonna is gonna be joined by juno
screenwriter diablo cody that's kind of
cool and producer amy pascal
oh yeah she did spider-man homecoming
you know yeah well then you've
been okay i'm not maybe not so much a
catastrophe
she cast tom holland which is pretty big
true
yeah so amy said this movie is an
absolute labor of love for me
i can't imagine anything more thrilling
than collaborating with her and diablo
on bringing her true life story to the
big screen
who's gonna play her i don't know it
just seems like this like
right in the beginning of of
pre-production or whatever like
who would you want to see play madonna
then me personally
michael jackson michael jackson
the first person that popped in my mind
was lindsey i really
like i'm trying to think about it
probably wouldn't be lindsay but that's
just the first
actress that came to mind i'm like
that'd be interesting
no joke and this sounds like a joke but
meryl streep
i just want to see what the [ __ ] she
would do yeah dude i rewatched devil
wears pride on the plane
coming back [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
amazing i think if
but she would have to still pull off the
dance moves the whole problem with the
irishman is that they still moved like
they were in their 70s and 80s whereas
at that point you might as well just get
madonna to do it herself then i guess
yeah just dh
that's probably two like she can't focus
as uh
true i mean some people do both i don't
know yeah
but not playing themselves do they
playing as them who stars in their own
biopic
yeah i like the bioptic
they should call it that that's what
david tried to call him biopic
isn't it biopic or no biopsy but it's
sicker
oh what's up no so we had this whole
discussion with david
um so he thought it was pronounced
biopic
yeah because he read about the fact that
it's
that's how it's pronounced but then it
was funny because in that same article
people were commenting because we
vlogged this people were commenting on
that vlog saying
in that same article they're explaining
how it's pronounced biopic
because it's a biographical picture
right
yeah i could swear
at some point i mean i've heard it
before i've heard people say biopsy
english i don't know weird they're
violent
yes they are wrong yeah anyone any other
actresses you guys would want to see
my personal favorite actress is emily
blunt but oh oh she'd be great
that's my favorite actress i [ __ ]
love her why do you love emily
what do you like what sell me on her
okay her personality is what wins me
over and also
in real life real life emily blunt i
[ __ ] love her personality she's so
witty she's
so yeah spunky like she's so like
love like i love her like just for being
her and then i look at her work
and the way she executes like she
[ __ ] kills it like in the devil worse
product she was so good in that movie
i forgot she's in that was so good in
that movie
my i had a problem with her as a mary
poppins though
but i feel like that's more of a
director problem i didn't see that
because
i mean i agreed to yeah i bet like i
mean i would definitely say that was
more of a director problem because it
was like
that her character was even close to
what mary poppins is supposed to be
there's nothing funny the guy being like
i had a problem with her as mary poppins
[Laughter]
good for you by the way i just love it
unapologetic mary poppins lover
get that [ __ ] tattooed okay that's not
my mary
[Laughter]
that's so mad i agree though i was i
watched that movie like i said i [ __ ]
love her but i'm like not this one yeah
this one didn't work didn't have the
magic yeah the same magic
wasn't og mary in that movie too yeah uh
or no she didn't she was done
it was uh in the movie she was still
alive
anyway i'm curious to see who ends up
playing madonna
in her biopic biopic god damn it
rings everything i'm calling it a biopic
now
okay which what does she call it i mean
what's the name of the movie what does
she call it i don't
i say she calls it ray of light because
she had an album
when she just found kabbalah called real
light and she loves that album but
people didn't really like it so she
might just kind of force [ __ ] it into
our brains
oh true pretty good and then she's also
a ray of light and that's the
yeah so that was that red string that
comes with it something like get the one
those things in every like dvd copy
[Music]
you